jubiläumsfeier bei der nato
doch der 70 jahrestag wird überschattet
von meinungsverschiedenheiten über die
zukunft der allianz deutschlands schüler
nur mittelmaß die neuesten pisa studie
offenbart es fehlt an kompetenzen im
lesen in mathe und naturwissenschaften
keine solidarität im profifußball werder
bremen soll die millionen kosten für
polizeieinsätze bei risikospielen
alleine tragen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hat
uns norbert könig mitgebracht ja stimmen
zum siebzigsten geburtstag der nato er
gebremste feierstimmung hatte der
französische präsident max sieht doch
gerade wenig schmeichelhaft hirntod
genannt dafür rückte in heute
ausgerechnet der mann der die nato
selbst einst als obsolet bezeichnet
hatte us-präsident trump in diesen
minuten gibt die queen zu ehren der nato
einen empfang im buckingham palast und
eröffnet das gipfeltreffen
und so hatte es angefangen zwölf länder
gründen 1949 in washington das
verteidigungsbündnis nato das ziel
sicherheit im kalten krieg geht es vor
allem um abschreckung stärke zeigen
gegen die sowjetunion das bündnis wächst
schnell
1955 tritt die bundesrepublik
deutschland bei mittlerweile hat die
nato 29 mitgliedstaaten gemeinsame
einsätze gibt es etwa im kosovo oder
nach dem 11 september 2001 in
afghanistan
die gemeinsamkeiten aber haben stark
nachgelassen wie dieser geburtstag zeigt
aus london jetzt elmar theveßen
für streit sorgt ja meistens don joo
aber heute lobt er lieber erst mal sich
selbst
dank ihm geben die nato-länder ja
künftig 130 milliarden dollar mehr aus
für ihre streitkräfte
dann wird er zum glühenden verteidiger
der nato beleidigend und gefährlich sei
das gerede des franzosen max vom gehirn
tot
es stimmt ja auch
die nato ist aktiv agil und passt sich
an eine sehr hässliche äußerung
gegenüber 28 ländern man kann nicht
einfach so was rom erzählen über die
nato das ist sehr respektlos und doch
schütteln die beiden sich dann die hände
trump hat es nur noch kleinen disput
aber makro bleibt bei seiner
grundsatzkritik fordert eine
neuausrichtung der nato unmöglich sagen
wir geben geld und soldaten ohne
klarheit darüber was die nato sein
sollte das ist unklar
unklar auch ob man selbst für den mann
den roten teppich ausrollen sollte der
mit der blockade aller beschlüsse in
london droht der türkische präsident
erdogan will dass die nato die kurdische
miliz upc zur terrororganisation erklärt
aber sein treffen mit der deutschen
kanzlerin und ihren amtskollegen aus
frankreich und großbritannien
zum einmarsch der türkei in syrien
bleibt ergebnislos
trotz des fröhlichen fotos bei allen
differenzen die es gibt und die wir
natürlich auch aussprechen müssen wir
müssen auch über die zukunft der nato
und die strategischen gemeinsamkeiten
diskutieren aber ich gehe relativ
optimistisch in dieses treffen hat sich
da denn noch ist offen ob die türkei in
großer runde morgen die gipfel schluss
erklärung mittragen wird in der unter
anderem china als mögliche neue
bedrohung genannt werden soll
aber für heute ist genug gestritten bei
der königin im buckingham palast soll es
harmonisch zugehen
immerhin feiert das bündnis ja
geburtstag kritik an der nato von makro
konstruktivem ehrungen von trump das
sind ja irgendwie verkehrte rollen bei
diesem gipfel stefan leifert oder ja so
ist es deswegen reiben sich hier bei der
nato in london auch viele verwundert die
augen und freuen sich darüber dass der
us präsident einen rollenwechsel
vollzogen hat vom disruptiven faktor hin
zur integrationsfigur der die nato in
schutz nimmt gegen die anwürfe von
präsident makro so groß die verärgerung
innerhalb der nato ist über die
äußerungen von makro sie beziehen sich
weil die verwunderung bezieht sich der
weitgehend auf die tonlage in der
analyse
diese in der diagnose die dem zugrunde
liegt können nämlich viele zustimmen
makro beklagte zum beispiel die fehlende
abstimmung innerhalb des bündnisses
viele fehlende strategien für viele
konfliktherde auf der welt da stimmen
viele zu- und deswegen ist die nato die
hier jetzt gerade hinter mir im
buckingham-palast vorfährt zum empfang
ein bündnis das sich zum siebzigsten
geburtstag ziemlich grundsätzlich in
frage gestellt
bei aller kritik am bündnis wird seine
zukunftsfähigkeit denn tatsächlich in
frage gestellt es geht hier weniger um
die frage ob die nato noch einen sinn
hat sondern eher um die frage wie sie
sich für künftige herausforderungen
aufstellen soll
deswegen wird hier morgen wahrscheinlich
eine gipfel erklärung verabschiedet wenn
sie denn eine mehrheit bekommt die den
generalsekretär der nato jens
stoltenberg damit beauftragt naja so
einen reflexionsprozess wie man das
nennt in gang zu setzen der ein oder
zwei jahre dauern soll um am ende zu
einer neuen strategie zu einem neuen
selbstbild zu kommen wenn das morgen
eine mehrheit bekommt dann hätte der
streit den makro angezettelt hat sogar
noch eine produktive wirkung gehabt
vielen dank für die analyse stefan
leifert in london
es ist keine ungetrübte geburtstagsfeier
bei der nato in london wo es konkret hat
das können sie nachlesen auf heute.de
außerdem die geschichte des
militärbündnisses in bildern
trump und macken haben in london auch
über den zoll streit zwischen ihren
ländern gesprochen
die usa drohen mit massiven strafzöllen
auf französische einfuhren wie etwa käse
oder champagner eine reaktion auf
frankreichs digital steuert die vor
allem große us internet konzerne trifft
die eu kommission unterstützt paris in
dem streit die eu werde als einheit
reagieren erklärte brüssel zur spd die
designierten vorsitzenden saskia esken
und norbert walter borjans haben zum
ersten mal mit dem erweiterten
parteipräsidiums über den zukünftigen
kurs beraten
es geht vor allem um einen leitantrag
für den parteitag am kommenden
wochenende
das neue spitzenduo will den fortbestand
der koalition von verhandlungen mit der
union abhängig machen etwa für mehr
klimaschutz und einen höheren
mindestlohn theo koll in berlin ist das
neue spitzenduo denn damit ohne weiteres
bei der bisherigen spd-führung
durchgedrungen
naja zumindest wurden heute gemeinsam
vier zentrale forderungen aufgestellt
weitere milliardeninvestitionen und das
dürfe nicht an einer schwarzen null
scheitern hieß es dazu ein
kurzarbeitergeld für von
digitalisierungs veränderungen
betroffene arbeitnehmer plus ein höherer
mindestlohn aber ohne konkreten betrag
zu nennen und genau so weichgespült wie
beim mindestlohn ist die forderung nach
mehr klimaschutz am donnerstag soll dann
endgültig der leitantrag stehen und
entschieden werden aber auf jeden fall
soll der nikolaus das ist der erste tag
des parteitags nicht die entscheidung
über das große ende bescheren
darüber soll es keine abstimmung geben
werden die groko kritiker denn mit
diesem papier auf dem parteitag
einverstanden sein
das wird die große unbekannte heute
vielen versöhnliche stichworte wie
besonnenheit und zusammenhalt man mache
ja kein provokation papier aber ob ein
dermaßen weichgespült klingender
leitantrag den groko kritikern unter den
600 parteitagsdelegierten reichen wird
das wird die große frage also freitag
wird der tag der entscheidung und das
könnte spannend werden
dank theo koll die mitarbeiter des
angeschlagenen stahlkonzerns
thyssenkrupp fürchten um ihre
arbeitsplätze und fordern ein
zukunftskonzept mehrere tausend
stahlarbeiter verlangten noch während
der sitzung des aufsichtsrats vor der
konzernzentrale in duisburg mehr geld
für moderne produktionsanlagen
thyssenkrupp steckt auch wegen der
billigkonkurrenz aus china und der
sinkenden nachfrage aus der
autoindustrie seit längerem in der krise
der konzern will 2000 stellen in der
stahlsparte streichen
2001 war der schock groß die pisa studie
der oecd zeigte dass die leistungen der
deutschen schüler schlechter waren als
der durchschnitt der industrieländer und
diesmal fällt das zeugnis durchwachsen
aus
zwar liegen die 15 jährigen schülerinnen
und schüler im lesen in mathematik und
den naturwissenschaften über dem
durchschnitt doch die leistungskurve
zeigt nach unten
beim rechnen erreichen die schüler etwa
den schlechtesten wert seit jahren
stefanie dosch und elisabeth schmidt mit
mehr details recherche im internet
lernalltag den meisten deutschen schulen
doch laut pisa-studie kann jeder zehnte
schüler nicht einschätzen ob eine quelle
im netz fakten oder meinungen wieder
gibt umso wichtiger die bildung in
diesem bereich also unsere lehrer also
meine lehrerin legt sehr viel wert
darauf dass wichtige informationen
finden
deshalb sagt sie offenbar untersucht
verschiedene quellen ich suche nur die
übersichtlichste und die einfachsten
wurde zum ersten mal untersuchte die
pisa studie auch die lesekompetenz in
der digitalen welt das gesamtergebnis in
allen bereichen die lesekompetenz liegt
in deutschland noch immer über dem
oecd-durchschnitt hat sich aber nach
2015 wieder verschlechtert der
lehrermangel ist ein faktor der in
diesem bericht eine stärkere rolle
gespielt hat das zeigt dass wir
weiterhin bei im bereich der bildung an
den schulen fortschritte machen müssen
im internationalen ranking liegt
deutschland zwar ebenfalls über dem oecd
durchschnitt aber unter anderem hinter
finnland hongkong singapur
diese investieren mehr in die bildung
kleinere klassen viele lehrer die haben
eben genau das wo wir also diese
anknüpfungspunkte von dem kleinkindalter
über die kita über die schule bis hin in
berufsschule oder hochschule haben die
einzige abgestimmtes system die geben
weiter und das ist etwas was wir ja auch
über als nationale kraftanstrengung
wollen dass sie über alle systeme die
wir haben sagen so wir setzen uns jetzt
einfach mal zusammen wichtig denn
erreichten 2009 sozial besser gestellte
schüler bereits 104 punkte mehr bei der
lesekompetenz als benachteiligte waren
es 2008 10 113 punkte noch einmal neun
prozent mehr schwache schüler werden
weiter abgehängt fazit deutschland
schließt in der pisa studie schlechter
ab als zuvor und das bildungssystem ist
noch immer nicht so leistungsfähig
andere russland weitet die überwachung
von journalisten und bloggern aus bisher
konnten schon ausländische medien als
agenten eingestuft werden
jetzt unterschrieb präsident putin ein
schärferes gesetz ab sofort können auch
journalisten die für solche ausländische
medien arbeiten als agenten gelten und
besonders überwacht werden der mord an
der journalistin darf ne caro anna
galizia auf malta hat vor zwei jahren
ganz europa schockiert vergangene woche
wurde ein mutmaßlicher drahtzieher des
bombenanschlags festgenommen
er beschuldigt mitglieder der
maltesischen regierung darin verwickelt
zu sein
eine delegation des europaparlaments ist
nun nach malta gereist um sich ein bild
zu machen
ministerpräsident muskat hat wegen der
anschuldigungen für januar seinen
rücktritt angekündigt in der hauptstadt
valletta forderten gestern wieder
tausende seinen sofortigen rückzug
antritt besuch in afghanistan
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer trifft auf ein land zwischen
andauernder gewalt und der hoffnung auf
verhandlungen in kabul sprach sie mit
der afghanischen regierung und forderte
einen direkten dialog der afghanischen
politik mit den taliban bisher
verhandeln die usa alleine mit den
militanten islamisten für uns ist
cornelia schiemenz dabei ein gruß nach
deutschland und dann zeigt die
afghanischen luftwaffe was sie gelernt
hat mit hilfe der bundeswehr deutsche
soldaten unterstützen bei logistik bei
technik bei ausbildung alle gemeinsam
hoffen sie hier auf frieden sind nicht
hoffnungslos wie afghanen wollen in
frieden leben in ruhe und ohne stress
ein wunsch den auch sie teilt für
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist es der
erste besuch in afghanistan
sie fordert dass die afghanische
regierung in friedensgespräche mit den
taliban eingebunden werden müsse das
gemeinsame ziel ein freies und
friedliches afghanistan
dafür arbeiten wir seite an seite
schon seit vielen jahren diese arbeit
zeigt folge und diese arbeit wollen wir
fortsetzen
beim besuch ihrer truppe zeigt die neue
chefin keine berührungsängste seit 19
jahren engagiert sich die bundeswehr im
norden afghanistans mit überschaubarem
erfolg
auch deshalb fordert die opposition
immer wieder eine politische überprüfung
dieses längsten auslandseinsatzes wir
jedenfalls wünschen uns klarere
kriterien an denen man messen kann was
wir eigentlich erzielen wollen und an
denen wir dann messen können sind wir
eigentlich wie viele schritte sind wir
in die richtige richtung vorangekommen
und wie viele schritte sind noch zu
gehen zwei schritte vor ein schritt
zurück die verteidigungsministerin dank
den soldaten und soldatinnen für ihren
einsatz
es ist eine bittere bilanz der
jahrelange internationale einsatz in
afghanistan hat im land keinen frieden
gebracht deshalb stellt sich die frage
nach dem sinn präsident trump sagte
immer wieder raus aus dem land und
sollten die amerikaner wirklich gehen
dann hieße es wohl auch für die
bundeswehr aus scheune bierzelt oder
doch architektonischer meilenstein
selten war ein projekt so umstritten wie
das geplante museum der moderne in
berlin
heute war der symbolische spatenstich
bis 2026 soll der bau auf dem gelände
zwischen der neuen nationalgalerie und
der philharmonie fertig sein und dann so
der plan mit viel platz licht und
reihenweise meisterwerken auch die
skeptiker überzeugen unter anderem
medaille hole picasso und beckmann ein
querschnitt also durchs gesamte
zwanzigste jahrhundert der und jetzt
kommen wir zu erfolgreichen handball
frauen die bei der weltmeisterschaft
weiter ungeschlagen sind nehmen und
damit schon vorzeitig die hauptrunde
erreicht haben also ganz tolle
zwischenbilanz lange mussten sie warten
um endlich mal wieder gegen den
dreimaligen olympiasieger und
angstgegner dänemark zu gewinnen
heute hat es geklappt denn kumamoto in
japan 26 zu 25 der dritte sieg im
dritten gruppenspiel
seit 19 jahren wieder mal ein
pflichtspiel erfolg gegen den
mitfavoriten starker beginn zehn zu vier
nach 8
minuten höchste führung im spiel mit
herz leib und seele ist der angegangen
haben ihre absprachen gut eingehalten
jeder auf ihre positionen doktorarbeit
auch als zehn minuten vor dem ende noch
einmal eng wird dänemark mit dem
einzigen ausgleich im spiel 22 22 aber
dann ist verlass auf sie julia behnke
zwei tore zum 24 22
den tipp mit sieben toren beste werferin
überragende diener eckel im tor mit
glück und geschick sicher den 26
25-erfolg deutschland in der hauptrunde
und extrem gut gelaunt hochrisikospiele
im profifußball versucht verursachen
hohe kosten bei den sicherheitsmaßnahmen
das land bremen hatte dem sv werder für
polizeieinsätze 1,17 millionen euro in
rechnung gestellt dem ansinnen des clubs
dass sich die anderen vereine der ersten
und zweiten liga an diesen kosten
beteiligen mögen hat die dfl jetzt eine
abfuhr erteilt gerade bei den bremer
derbys gegen den hamburger sv kommt es
regelmäßig zu schweren fan
ausschreitungen
die folge noch mehr polizeikräfte als
bei normalen spielen beim treffen der
profi vereine unter dfl in der nähe von
frankfurt linken die anderen klubs ab
sich an dem bremer kosten von mehr als
einer million euro zu beteiligen
den entsprechenden kosten bescheid des
landes bremen hatte das
bundesverwaltungsgericht bestätigt
werder bremen beklagt fehlende
solidarität
wir haben eine situation dass man uns
hier mit den polizeikosten jetzt zu 100
prozent belasten möchte und das können
wir als geschäftsführung da drinnen
nicht einfach so hinnehmen
werder bremen will jetzt den rechtsweg
gehen um eine beteiligung der anderen
profivereine zu erreichen einige weitere
bundesländer prüfen derzeit ob sie
vereine ebenfalls zur kasse bitten
ja das wird noch viele juristen weiter
beschäftigen wann genau wird beim wetter
gibt es sonnige aussichten für morgen
die details erfahren sie gleich von
osten terry so viel von uns danke dass
sie dabei waren
claus kleber mit dem heute journal um
21.45 und hier freut sich morgen
christian sievers auf sie wir wünschen
auch einen gemütlichen abend und sagen
tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ruhiges
hochdruckwetter erwartet uns mit diesem
hoch hier das wandert allmählich
richtung südosten und so gibt es morgen
sonnenschein in der nacht jedoch nebel
und zwar von der ems runter bis zum 1
und da kann sich auch reifglätte bilden
ja ansonsten im nordosten viele wolken
an der ostsee sogar regen im süden klart
es auf und dort wird es am kältesten mit
temperaturen bis minus 8 grad also hier
die kälteste ecke deutschlands und die
mildeste ecke mit 7 grad in
schleswig-holstein morgen zunächst
einmal nebel der erlöst sich dann auf
und dann zeigt sich die sonne vor allem
im süden viel sonnenschein
nach norden hin gibt zwar auch viele
wolken aber gelegentlich zeigt sich auch
dort mal die sonne temperaturen dazu mit
acht grad entlang der küsten und 1 grad
im südwesten deutschlands
am donnerstag wird es noch sonnig und
relativ ruhig sein bei temperaturen von
ein bis sieben grad am freitag liegt der
wind zu und es kommt regen auf vor allem
an der nordsee dann stürmischer wind ja
und das bei 1 bis 10 grad es wird also
auch etwas milder samstag dann ähnliches
wetter mit regen und viel wind aber an
der nordsee dann etwas ruhiger damit ein
schöner abend